Pentingnya quantum computing sebenarnya diremehkan
sekaligus dilebih-lebihkan secara bersamaan.
Meskipun tidak akan menggantikan komputer konvensional,
inovasi quantum merepresentasikan paradigma komputasi baru.
Komputer quantum bisa bekerja seiring dengan infrastruktur komputasi
saat ini untuk memecahkan masalah kompleks yang sebelumnya
dianggap tidak praktis atau mustahil.
Ini bisa mengubah paradigma secara drastis.
Misalnya, sulitnya memfaktorkan bilangan besar
menjadi bilangan prima adalah dasar dari
kriptografi modern. Untuk ukuran bilangan yang digunakan dalam enkripsi
kunci publik-privat modern, perhitungan ini akan memakan waktu
bagi komputer konvensional tercepat lebih dari 300 triliun tahun.
Bagi komputer quantum berskala besar yang bekerja
dengan algoritma Shor, perhitungan ini bisa selesai dalam hitungan detik.
Masalah-masalah kompleks seperti ini ada di semua industri.
Potensi aplikasi quantum computing
sangat luas.
Komputer quantum sudah semakin besar
dan semakin canggih,
seiring kita berupaya menangani masalah yang lebih rumit.
Sejak 2016, IBM telah membuat komputer quantum bisa diakses
oleh publik melalui sebuah website dengan antarmuka grafis yang
tampilannya seperti partitur musik,
dan software development kit Qiskit
yang memungkinkan pengguna memprogram komputer quantum.
Para ilmuwan di dalam maupun di luar dunia korporat
sedang menjalankan eksperimen
melalui portal serupa. Mereka mengeksplorasi pendekatan untuk kimia
dan masalah machine learning, mencoba memahami
pertanyaan apa yang bisa mereka ajukan
dan bagaimana mereka akan membingkai pertanyaan-pertanyaan itu
begitu teknologinya sudah lebih maju. Sekaranglah
saat yang tepat bagi para pemimpin bisnis untuk bersiap
menghadapi quantum. Kondisinya sudah ada untuk bereksperimen
dan mengembangkan teknologi baru yang fundamental ini.
Organisasi yang ingin berada di garis
terdepan dari perubahan transformasional ini akan
meraih keunggulan kompetitif. Pelatihan ini
akan mempersiapkan kamu untuk memulai perjalanan quantum-mu!